from exclusive items to portion sizes we
wanted to find out all the differences
between Cadbury products in the US and
the UK this is food
wars in the UK classic dairy milk
chocolate comes in a bunch of sizes the
smallest one isn't sold individually but
it's one of these selection box
bite-size pieces then we move up to one
of these little bars these are sold
mostly as a snack for children and they
weigh 18 G each then we have a multi
pack bar which weighs 33.5 G then we
have what I would say is the standard
bar which is 45 G if you're feeling
hungry you can have a Duo bar as you can
see by the crease in the middle it's
kind of separated into two smaller bars
and in total it weighs 54.4 G in terms
of standard dairy milk you may also be
able to find a 95 G bar we actually
found a 90 G bar of caram milk the
portion size varies slightly depending
on what type of chocolate you're getting
moving more in towards the larger sizes
we have a 110 G bar of dairy milk up
from that we have a 180 g bar our second
biggest size is this 360 G bar and
finally our biggest size is this
one that's 850 g of dairy milk in the US
our dairy milk bars come in one size the
3.5 o or 99.2 G bar now this bar right
next to it the Caramelo is actually 4 oz
or 113.5 G right here in the middle
there's a fruit nut size that's 5.4 Oz
or 153 G I couldn't get it in
time but our I guess biggest size or
other size is this a bag of Miniatures
where it is an 8 oz or 22 G bag but it's
always these little guys in there our
cadburry bar the 99.2 G bar comes in 18
squares per bar if you divide it up it's
6 G per square for comparison we'll take
a look at our 110 G bar of dairy milk in
the UK One of These Bars has 24
individual squares we're going to find
out how much one of those weighs so
according to our slightly inaccurate
analog scales one square weighs around 6
G although if we divide the 110 figure
by 24 we end up with around 4.5 so
somewhere between there so there's no
difference good on your
cabry here are all the Cadbury products
from the UK that you won't find in the
US and here are all the Cadbury products
from the US you won't find in the UK
this is going to be an easy one for me
now I want to remind the audience that
this is for Cadbury products produced in
our respective countries yes all that
stuff is available on Amazon we know now
obviously we have a ton of exclusive
products here in the UK so we're going
to break them down into categories we'll
start with standard dairy milk bars but
with different flavorings we're going to
start off with a bang here with what's
possibly my favorite just standard Dairy
Milk Bar which is cabri whole nut it's
basically fruit and nut but with none of
that gross fruit in there it's just the
nuts fruit and
nut whole nut now depending on what time
of year you're looking for your cab in
the supermarket you might be able to
find Orange Dairy Milk but because we're
in the buildup to the festive season we
got winter orange crisp instead
chocolate and orange is kind of a
beloved flavor combination here in the
UK I think a lot of people will think of
Terry's chocolate oranges but cabri are
getting in on the ACT too next up we
have cab dairy milk Oreo you might see a
few of these as we go through they seem
to have some kind of partnership going
on with Oreo because there's actually
quite a few dairy milk X Oreo products
I'll open this one up because it's
actually quite cool what they've done to
be fair from the outside it looks just
like a standard piece of dairy milk but
if you see they've actually filled it
with Oreo
cream but they also put little pieces of
the biscuit in so you get these like
crunchy bits as well if the cab dairy
milk Oreo somehow isn't sweet enough for
you you can also get a white chocolate
Oreo bar we're sticking with the
classics here and we're moving on to
dairy milk caramel now I know I said
that this might have been too sweet for
me but I actually do really like the
caramel bars so what you get is dairy
milk chocolate but then you have this
quite liquidy caramel on the
inside the caramel it is sweet but it's
not like it's not like you're just
tasting sugar you know there is
something else going on there we did see
that in the US you guys have Caramelo is
that kind of the same thing Joe what do
you think hi Harry and yes we don't have
the dairy milk caramel we have the dairy
milk Caramelo I remember Caramelo for a
while was a US brand I remember the
commercials it went like
Caramelo so that's your let's take a
look at ours here's ours it's already
like kind of coming out there it's
caramel heavy rich I guess yeah I can't
got a straight answer if CAD just bought
Caramelo in the US and repackaged it or
what but it looks like it's probably
relatively the same sticking with the
caramel theme we now have the new salted
caramel bar I feel like I don't know if
this is the case in the US but there's
been a real salted caramel Takeover in
the past couple of years to the point
where it's very hard to find unsalted
caramel now and I suppose
Cadbury had to get on the
trend I really don't think I taste much
if any difference at all between that
and the regular Caro since I have
nothing else to do for this episode I'm
going to go ahead and try some of you
this UK cadberry I'm hearing so much
about starting with the OG cadberry
Dairy Milk
Bar yeah this is a much smoother nicer
richer creamier chocolate
I do really love this it's fantastic you
brag a lot about your chocolate UK but
another thing you should be bragging
about is your caramel it's also really
good and way better than what we have in
America so the caramelos from earlier I
just not not the not the biggest fan of
those anymore I like that one as was a
kid but caramel in America is just too
but yours oh
yeah I mean pulls apart nicer now this
one got cheers of approval from the crew
when I mentioned it this is the cabri
dairy milk dime BX now for those who
don't know dime is a chocolate bar in
its own right and it's like a layer of
chocolate on the outside with quite a
hard layer of kind of toffee caramel on
the inside now dime bars themselves I
think have maybe fallen out of favor a
little bit in the UK they were very
popular with kind of like my granddad's
generation and I think people don't
really buy them on their own anymore
however I do say they are delicious you
can also still buy them in places like
Ikea I think they're popular kind of on
Continental Europe next up we have
another new bar it's the Cadbury white
confetti bar I've never seen this before
before I went to do shopping for this
episode but it's white chocolate and it
contains oat biscuit pieces as well as
milk chocolate beans but you do see
quite a few of these biscuit
pieces yeah I get a lot of the
biscuit not much of the chocolate pieces
you may also be able to find a mint
dairy milk a crunchy pieces dairy milk
and also dairy milk with 30% less sugar
but I wasn't able to try them down today
then we have a couple of dairy milk bars
with either slightly different
compositions or flavors firstly we have
dairy milk marvelous Creations this one
has jelly popping candy inside don't
quote me on this but I feel like back in
the early 2000s in the UK we had a Wonka
series of chocolate bars which were
inspired by Willie Wonka now I think
that was actually a Nestle product but
they had interesting flavors they did
things like putting jelly beans and
popping candy into their chocolate bars
they've disappeared don't know what
happened to them but I feel like this is
C's attempt to like get in on that bring
that back a little bit probably pretty
well timed because uh you know the Wonka
movie is out soon it's going to really
date this video but we love Shalom these
are pretty good I do think it's like an
interesting textural experience when you
eat one of these because it's the kind
of chewi of the Jelly Bean mixed in with
the melty milk chocolate not my favorite
but hey if you want something a little
bit different then this is for you then
we're on to the big taste bars this is
the dairy milk big taste Oreo crunch I
did mention that there was a theme of
dairy milk and Oreo crossover products
and this is the next one in that line so
with the big taste bars They are thicker
than a standard chocolate bar would be
and because of that they have like
layers going on basically double the
height so here is the standard dairy
milk Oreo and here is the big taste Oreo
as you can see you get much more
distinct layers on this
one I'm going to be honest I think I
just prefer the standard one one iconic
cab product is the Fredo a Fredo is a
small individually wrapped chocolate bar
that's in the shape of a frog now you
can get two versions of this you can
either get a standard one which is just
milk chocolate or you can get a caramel
Fredo much like a dairy milk caramel bar
it's a shell of milk chocolate with that
kind of liquidy caramel on the inside I
love fedos I feel like a lot of Brits
have a nostalgic attachment to them I
can't tell if they've shrunk over the
years or if I've just got bigger or
possibly both but I do feel like back in
the day when you're a little kid these
are a nice little like snack siiz treat
whereas nowadays this is like a mouthful
this is kind of tiny they're also worth
pointing out because in the UK they've
become an unlikely economic yard stick
when I was a kid they cost just 10 P but
the price has risen drastically over the
past few years at one point in 2017 the
price Rose as high as 30p for one of
these whereas I think it's now dropped
back down to 25 after probably a lot of
public outcry because of the fluctuating
price they've kind of become a measure
of inflation and cost of living here in
the UK people's paychecks do not buy
them as many fros as they used to and
that is a sad thing that's funny Harry
and the US Carberry tried what I think
are similar Shenanigans by decreasing
the size of the products back in 2007 us
comedian and actor BJ Novak outed
Cadbury on the Conan O'Brien show for
suddenly making Cadbury eggs smaller in
the UK we also have a couple of
plant-based chocolate options they're
made with almonds instead of dairy in
order to try and replicate a milk
chocolate feel and they come in two
forms either as a classic bar or as a
salted
caramel it's actually not that bad
they've done really well I think to
replicate the texture of milk chocolate
cuz as it kind of claims on the
packaging smooth I think is the word it
really is quite a smooth experience it
does kind of melt in your mouth almost
like a milk chocolate farwood I think
what's letting it down really for me is
still the taste of it rather than the
texture it tastes almost more like a
sort of uh cooking chocolate or like you
know when you get those really cheap
chocolate chips and feels like there
isn't enough cocoa or like creaminess to
them we have these four
exclusive bars here in the US we got uh
Rock the road which is milk chocolate
with roasted almonds
marshmallows and
fudge no I don't like that we have a
royal dark dark chocolate I'm sure you
have several dark chocolates ours is
Royal not a big dark chocolate
guys not as bitter as I expect from dark
chocolate so not bad but I don't know
again just okay roasted
almond generous with the almonds right
it's a pretty good almond almond haul
last of our exclusive flavors are black
forest cake which is dark chocolate with
cherry flavored fudge and cookie pieces
oh man okay so apparently in the UK you
would call us a black black forest gate
which is funny cuz you didn't use the
French words for black or Forest well
black
forest oh yeah that's right and the
black forest in Germany EU you guys
don't know what's going on uh going to
be honest with you chocolate and Cherry
not my favorite
combo oh God this is terrible this is
the worst one oh I hate this next up
we're on to buttons now cab buttons are
just pieces of dairy milk chocolate
shaped into little buttons or little
buttons come in a range of sizes and
flavors so the original ones are
actually tiny I feel like they've kind
of fallen out of favor or maybe you're
just kind of only given to kids but this
is what honestly the classic button
looks like and it's these really tiny
little chocolate discs it's literally
just plain dairy milk chocolate the ones
that I would more commonly go for in my
adult life are the ones which are served
in these big sharing bags and they're
more like this size you say that's like
that's more than double the size I would
say and then if that button size is
still not big enough for you then we
have mega buttons so we have classic
Giant and mega just one more note on the
size of the buttons we've observed that
the classic ones on the packet are just
called
buttons but what I think used to be
called the giant ones are also now just
called
buttons which you can see because they
are still called giant buttons in the
orange flavored version you can also get
buttons in a range of flavors so here we
have some mint chocolate buttons some
orange chocolate buttons these ones are
called caramel nibbles but I always
thought they were just caramel buttons
because again they're kind of the disc
shape but with a little pocket of
caramel in the middle and you can also
get dark milk buttons now these are a
cabri invention which is somewhere
between dark chocolate and milk
chocolate as well as Cara milk buttons
and if you want just actual dark
chocolate cabri calls that bourneville
and they have giant bourneville dark
chocolate buttons another cabry product
in the UK are caby fingers now these are
a classic I feel like these are a staple
in a lot of British households basically
what you get is a layer of biscuit along
the bottom which is then kind of just
completely dunked in Capri milk
chocolate can't figure out exactly what
the biscuit is I think it's kind of like
shortbread you can also get cabry
fingers in a range of sizes and flavors
for example you can get these little
bite-sized pouches we have the Salted
Caramel fingers here but you can also
find white chocolate fingers orange
chocolate fingers mint chocolate fingers
and dark one thing which is just
launched in the UK at the time of
filming is Cadre Delights these are a
new range of products which I believe
are nouar covered in chocolate these
come in the flavors of hazelnut and
caramel orange and caramel and salted
caramel another exclusive we have in the
US are the mini chocolate eggs Harvest
eggs but it's around the holidays right
now so we have instead mini
snowballs I feel like they're the same
these are the same come
on yeah just milk chocolate with a uh
crisp sugary shell is to say on here
good for snack
I think um I think these taste the best
out of everything here to be
honest also have the cream eggs couldn't
find them anywhere I thought they used
to be everywhere now they're gone I
don't know what happened to them but you
know what they look like we have them
tragically we're filming this in
November so we can't get our hands on
our seasonal egg exclusives cab is
obviously known for cream eggs but also
has Mini Eggs which I believe are
excellent in the UK we can obviously get
the classic Cream Egg but we can also
get white cream eggs and caramel eggs we
can also get classic Mini Eggs as well
as a Mini Eggs bar however I will point
out that because it's in the runup to
Christmas we are able to get Heroes
right now which is a cab selection box
typically eaten around the holidays as
part of a Heroes box you can get a
little bite-sized Twisted Cream Egg Bar
I get that like you know you want to
create that artificial demand but I feel
like people are going to eat cream eggs
year round regardless of availability so
I feel like you should just give the
people what they want have cream eggs
year round same for Mini Eggs please I
need those much more than cream eggs now
we're on to some exclusive chocolate
bars which you'll find in the UK but not
the US going to go through them in like
a roughly alphabetical order here
starting with the Boost bar now I
believe when these were first introduced
they were almost advertised as like an
energy bar in chocolate form because I
think they had like mortifying levels of
sugar and glucose in them whereas now I
think they've actually dialed back on
that and it's kind of just like a
chocolate bar with some biscuit and
caramel in the middle at the Boost bar
give me the Boost M everyone in the UK's
watch me like this dummy's never had
this before no I haven't or if I had I
don't remember it now you might remember
from the buttons but when you see dark
chocolate and cadb it's going to be
marketed as bourneville comes in this
iconic red packaging as well compared to
the usual Purple colors used by
Cadbury's fun fact bourneville is
actually a real town which you can visit
in the UK it was created basically by
Cadbury to house all of their workers
and apparently it's quite a nice place
to live I'm not sure why they've ended
up using that name for their dark
chocolate range but here it is you can
get it in a few different flavors here
for example I have the old Jamaica
Flavor which is a dark chocolate with
rum and raisin we also have the
bourneville mint crisp bar you can also
just get it in a standard plain dark
chocolate one as well as an orange bar
as well next up we have caramilk so as
the name suggest this is kind of like a
caramell milk chocolate hybrid which
cabri has released over the past couple
of years what you end up with is this
like slightly weird yellowy golden
color kind of weird because it's got the
texture of like a milk chocolate but the
flavor is much closer to like a buttery
fudge you can also get caram milk in the
form of a caramel crispy butter
which is caram milk chocolate with
little crisped rice pieces speaking of
crunch next up we have a crunchy bar
these are pretty iconic basically what
you get is a honeycomb which is then
dipped in milk chocolate to produce a
crunchy barath when I say honeycomb
obviously there's no actual beehive in
here what you do is you mix melted sugar
and I believe baking soda and it kind of
like erates and puffs up and then
solidifies to leave you with what we
know as kind of I guess like confection
as honeycomb again slightly
controversial take I don't like crunchy
I don't don't like the texture of the
honeycomb on my teeth it feels really
weird and I don't enjoy it but I know
it's a very popular bar so you do you
that's fine next up is another possible
favorite of mine it's a curly whirly now
I love these because it sounds like an
American has kind of like improvised the
name for a British chocolate bar they're
a little bit hard to describe It's a
combination of chocolate and
toffee but it's in this very distinctive
unique shape I'm not really sure what
the logic is behind the shape but
I'm not sure if the same distinction
exists in America but here in the UK If
we say something has toffee in it that
implies that it's going to be very chewy
kind of similar to caramel in terms of
The Taste but a lot more
chewy curly whes let's go I have had
these before and I do really like them
oh
yeah yeah next up we have some more dark
milk products again this sits somewhere
between dark and milk chocolate on the
kind of cocoa content scale this one is
flavored with some little salted caramel
pieces more of the Salted Caramel again
with the Salted Caramel we get it it's
fine you might also be able to find the
same bar but flavored with some hazelnut
prene pieces next up is another classic
it's a Double Deca bar our buses aren't
the only things that are double decker
here in the UK we also have these
chocolate bars there's like quite a lot
going on in a double decker bar I do
love them I'm going to be honest but so
what you get is obviously the dairy milk
chocolate coating on the
outside then on the inside you see you
have this big layer of noua and on the
other side you have lots of these little
crispy I think kind of like crispy rice
pieces moving on from that we have a
flake so I don't really understand how
flakes are made but they are quite
impressive basically I think what they
do is they get like a kind of like
waterfall of chocolate and the way that
it kind of like hits the refrigerated
surface it kind of like folds in on
itself and you get this really like
layered flaky texture flakes are pretty
iconic the main use of flakes argu in
the UK is in ice cream cones what you
will usually get is a whipped ice cream
cone Mr whippy and then they just stick
of flake in there as well flakes have
also apparently been the center of some
uh controversy this year because due to
the weird structure of them they don't
melt now unlike most of the chocolate
that I've been trying today I've kind of
Come Away with like little bits of
melted chocolate on my hand but
basically due to how thin the layers of
the chocolate are when it melts the
solids and the fats don't really
separate like they should do and
therefore it just can't melt you can put
one of these in like a ban Marie and it
will just not melt you can microwave one
and it will just burn before it starts
to melt the fun facts don't stop there
we're rolling straight in to the fries
chocolate cream woo now obviously these
do not have the same
packaging or branding as the rest of
them but they are indeed manufactured by
cadb so these are bars of dark chocolate
with a fondant cream Center they're
worthy of special mention because these
are some of the first ever mass-produced
choc chocolate bars they take their name
from the fry family who were a Quaker
family from Bristol in the UK now the
fries were actually the first people to
figure out how to make mass-produced
chocolate bars we're going all the way
back to the 1840s here in the UK but
around that time people only really
drank chocolate it was quite rare to get
like you know a piece of chocolate or a
chocolate bar the fries were the first
ones who figured out how to press cacao
beans to separate the fats from the
solids now they were doing this just to
try and make a drinking powder that was
kind of easier to dissolve but
inadvertently figured out how to
separate all the materials and then
reincorporate them in order to make a
shelf stable chocolate
barath that's a taste of History right
there this is the packaging it's a fries
chocolate cream the packaging of this
one is suspicious it's like lowest
effort of packaging it's just this white
text no drop shadow a little bit of the
uh the bar right
there no I do not like this no well
they're not technically products
themselves rather an amalgamation of
products we have some selection boxes
here in the UK which are worth pointing
out now these will start to pop up in
stores around Christmas time which is
when they're usually eaten now these are
what's known as a selection box so
basically you have small individual
versions of quite a few of their
different chocolate bars which you can
then share with the family so the box of
Heroes will contain aa's fudge whisper
dairy milk crunchy bits twirl dairy milk
caramel double decer and the Cream Egg
Twisted we also have roses and these
aren't really based on existing Brands
these are more just like classic
chocolate box selections I suppose so we
have things like the orange cream the
strawberry dream we do actually have
some mini Dairy Milk bars in here now as
well as a few other ones I feel like in
my power rankings of all the chocolate
selection boxes I don't know if the
cabri ones win for me I do think
celebrations might win for me which is
like the Mars brand equivalent of these
ones I'm think it's probably
celebrations Heroes roses on quality
Street of course the classics man
British Christmas what a wonderful time
while we're talking about selection
boxes I should also mention the milk
tray now these are a classic these been
going back years and years and years I
feel like it's less of a thing now but
these were very very popular to gift to
people whether you know someone's had
you around for a dinner party or it's a
birthday give someone a milk tray back
in like the kind of 60s or 70s it was
just the dumb thing to do back to the
chocolate bars this is a picnic bar I
actually don't know if I've ever had a
picnic bar before mostly because they
contain raisins it's a milk chocolate
bar but then inside it's kind of just
like a mixture of everything you get
raisins you get peanuts there's crispy
cereal in there I think there's carot as
well next up is the Cadbury timeout
wafer I'd say this is more of a biscuit
bar than a chocolate bar but you have
layers of biscuit and chocolate which
are then obviously coated in more cavy
dairy milk chocolate then we're on to a
twirl these are kind of similar to the
flake in terms of the texture it's kind
of like flak texture inside but the
actual individual bars are coated with
chocolate twirl what is a
twirl no I like this it's just okay I I
don't like I don't like the um the Airy
texture of it man these are classic I
feel like these have almost gone extinct
this is a Chomp bar it's kind of the
same as a curly whirly in that it's
basically a layer of toffee covered in
milk chocolate but instead of that like
weird patterning with the gaps this is
just a solid bar I feel like these have
always been served in this kind of small
size bar as more of a snack maybe aimed
towards kids but I love a Chomp he's a
brilliant sh it's a whisper bar I don't
fully understand whisper bars I like
them don't get me wrong but it just kind
of like feels like you're getting less
chocolate for your money than you are
with some other bars because basically
they've taken a milk chocolate bar but
they've figured out how to air rate it
and kind of like put little air bubbles
in what they've really gone for is a
texture where when you bite into it it
almost like melts on your tongue we also
have a whisper gold bar whisper gold is
the same air rated texture but it has a
layer of caramel running along the top
next up we have a star bar now the way I
see it this is just like a better picnic
bar so a star bar is basically just milk
chocolate on the outside caramel and
peanuts next up we have the fudge bar
it's a layer of fudge with some cabry
chocolate on the outside they're still
in the heroes box which I like but I
feel like not that many people like them
anymore and then finally for the time
being aa's so the cabir is very
different to the pastry eair it's
basically a bow of toffee with chocolate
on the inside I always like these Al
there's always something really
satisfying about the texture of toffee
to me I had braces as a little kid and I
really missed tofe when I had
braces so I'll never take tofe for
granted again now Cadbury in the US is a
brand that's manufactured by Hershey so
there's no sub Brands under Cadbury in
the United States however Hershey does
own about 29 Brands here are a few that
are exclusives to the US in no
particular order first one milk Dud been
to movie theater in the US recognize
that sound some jerk sitting two rows
behind doesn't understand he's making
noise he got Milk Duds Milk Duds are
like Curly whirlies in button form yeah
that's actually pretty good what I just
did there it is just caramel covered in
chocolate but it is in button form and
not like drizzle form
these guaranteed stuck to your teeth
guaranteed you're digging these out of
your teeth a heath bar is hang on
English toffee en robed inrich chocy
coating they they wrote that like they
thought an American would read that and
be like this is from England Mounds is
chocolate and coconut there it is it's a
mound looks a little bit like a rabbit
turd it's just a chunk of
coconut covered in dark chocolate now if
you're looking at this and you're being
like it needs something else Joe yes it
does how about almonds Almond Joy the
exact same thing as a Mounds
but if said rabbit ate a bunch of
Almonds whole coconut and chocolate
coconut almonds and chocolate some of
the bars are also available in the form
of these bite-sized pieces these come in
bags notably we have some crunchy rocks
we have bits of whisper we have curly
whirly Squires and the least fun name 12
bites these are more designed to be
shared than obviously a classic
chocolate bar would be I think the idea
is maybe you get a bag of these take it
into the cinema or something watch a
film good a little snack next up we have
brunch bars these are Capri's take on
cereal bars we've got these brunch bars
in three different flavors we have a
raisin one a milk choc chip one and a
dark choc chip one I do actually quite
like these these were like a occasional
packed lunch inclusion when I was
growing up basically it's a cereal bar
made mostly with
oats but then you get this base layer of
chocolate as well as in this case some
choc chips as
well yeah they've got like a nice chewy
texture and then finally it's time for
what we'll call the best of the rest
these are the kind of miscellaneous
cabry products which don't really fit
into any of the other categories but are
still worth talking about firstly we
have animal
biscuits these were again like a classic
pack lunch staple when I was younger you
get a little biscuit which on one side
is kind of like decorated in the shape
of an animal and on the other side is
just dipped in dairy milk chocolate got
to give a shout out to mini rolls these
are another like maybe Grandma biscuit
tin staple these are actually like a
cake basically rather than a biscuit or
a chocolate bar it's a roll of chocolate
sponge cake which is then like I say
rolled up with a little like layer of
cream in the middle and then the whole
thing is dipped in milk chocolate as
well and then while we're talking about
cadb cakes we also have cadb cake bars
kind of similar to mini rolls in that
you have the chocolate sponge it's all
coated in chocolate as well but you have
that caramel layer along the top then
we're on to a couple of fridge desserts
these are Cadbury's milk chocolate
sticky puds so these are great I've had
like these or an iteration of these many
times in the past basically they come in
these little plastic pots which are
microwavable and the typical way to eat
these is that you maybe piss the film on
this put the whole thing in the
microwave for 30 seconds a minute or so
take it it out flip it onto a plate and
it comes out cooking it kind of like
steams the sponge when it's in there and
then there's like a chocolate sauce as
you can see on the packaging which is
kind of collected at this end and then
when you flip it ends up kind of like
drizzling down the side of the puds and
it's very nice like a fun kind of like
fancy feeling dessert that you can just
have at home in 30 seconds PUD of course
is short for pudding which is what we
call dessert and then we also have these
dairy milk pots of Joy these are
apparently a smooth and creamy dessert
made with melted Cadbury milk chocolate
I've not had one of these before I think
they're like a yogurt basically like a
chocolate yogurt pot I'm not sure what
to make of this next one because it
feels a little bit like America is
infiltrating our CPR products but this
is kaby dairy milk fruer and nuttier
orange trail mix these I believe are new
I don't think Cab's been doing trail mix
for a very long time I also don't think
trail mix is very popular in the UK in
general like it's just not that common
so in a bag of this apparently you get
sweetened cocoa dairy milk orange
buttons raisins and sultanas roasted
almonds and hazelnuts speaking of things
meant to sound English it's a York
Peppermint Patty all the way from the
city of York it is this and is just
instead of coconut it
is peppermint Mr good
bar chocolate and peanuts this bar the
packaging you can tell this is an old
school bar this bar is so old that his
main selling point was like we assure
you there's peanuts in this we're not
lying to you all right yes you won't
believe how packed with peanuts this bar
is is this true to the to
the the get the good bar guarantee on
the back possibly more wow they they
overd delivered on the promise of
peanuts Fifth Avenue bu I don't know
what this
is whatam I call it let's go chocolate
peanut flavor crisps and
caramel definitely very peanut buttery
it's okay we have two options when it
comes to beverages for Cades in the UK
here we have original Cadbury hot
chocolate and then we also have
highlights milk chock drink I'm not
massively sure what the difference is
but I think just judging from kind of a
look on the packaging highlights might
be designed as kind of like a diet
option just because it's described as an
instant low calorie milk chocolate
flavor hot drink staying in the cupboard
section of the Cab's aisle now we're on
to the chocolate spread this is
effectively kind of like a Nutella but
it doesn't have hazelnuts in it so this
is just like a pure chocolate spread now
we're moving on to the bakery section of
your Supermarket I got most of these
from an Asda in London so I do think the
availability will vary slightly
depending on where you are in which
Supermarket you're visiting but I will
say that most supermarkets will have a
bakery section and you'll probably see
some cabry Browning in there somewhere
here's what I was able to find we have
three of these bagged goods from the
bakery at Asda range firstly we have
some oaty bakes which are oat Flapjacks
containing milk chocolate next up we
have some cabri daa milk shorty squares
shorties like a
melody in my Square shorty squares are a
short cake packed with again some dairy
milk chocolate chunks then we have some
cabi dairy milk chocolate cookies we're
staying in the bakery aisle now we're on
to dairy milk caramel Donuts now I'm
kind of intrigued by these I love
donuts it's just very dry and then we
have a few more baked goods namely dairy
milk caramel mini cookies dairy milk
cornflake cluster bites and some dairy
milk brownie bites then we're going to
round things off with a few seasonal
items as I mentioned unfortunately we
weren't able to get the Easter
exclusives which are pretty iconic
namely the Cream Egg and the mini egg
but because we're kind of in the
Christmas Halloween period I was able to
get some of those exclusives instead
we'll start with the Halloween ones
which has just come and gone here in the
UK but we were able to find some mini
bonfire logs which are fun I think these
are like a mini roll but instead of the
classic kind of chocolate sponge they've
used a honey honeycomb sponge instead
and then another spooky seasonal
exclusive are the pumpkin patch cakes
these are chocolate cakes with an orange
colored cream filling then we have some
Cadbury Christmas puds these are dairy
milk chocolate bowls with a hazelnut
truffle Center hazelnut pieces and rice
crisps again it's that combination of
like chocolate and nuts just can't go
wrong for me and of course we can't talk
about seasonal exclusives without
talking about Advent calendars we love
our Advent calendars over here CAD Brees
of course has to get involved and they
have a very simple but very effective
chocolate Advent
calendar this 110 Grand Bar of cabri
dairy milk cost 135 at Tesco breaking
that down you're paying 1.22 per gram of
chocolate in the US our bar is 99 G and
it cost
$2.79 which is
2.8 per gram so per gram it's a 91%
increase in the US ooh getting gouged
[Music]
baby here's everything in a bar of dairy
milk chocolate in the UK milk sugar
cocoa butter cocoa Mass vegetable fats
palm and Shea emulsifiers e442 ammonium
phosphatides e476 polyglycerol poly
rolate and flavoring here's everything
in a US dairy milk chocolate bar we got
sugar milk chocolate cocoa butter
lactose leathan PG PR natural flavor
artificial flavor UK chocolate is often
considered as Superior by some including
myself to us chocolate and there are a
few reasons for that firstly the UK
rules for its chocolate production from
the cocoa and chocolate products
regulations of 2003 set minimums for
milk chocolate at 25% too fat cocoa
butter and milk fat 5% milk fat 20% dry
cocoa solids 2.5% dry non-fat cocoa
solids and 20% dry milk solids in the US
our FDA rules for our milk chocolate
differ quite a bit 10% chocolate laor
12% milk salads which can be either
powder or condensed milk at least
3.39% fat and no more than 55% sugar
secondly those of us on this side of the
Atlantic can feel that American
chocolate has a sour almost vomity taste
to it that's all very well and good for
American branded chocolate bars but why
doesn't us Cadbury taste like it does
over here in the UK it starts with the
Hershey Company back in the early 1900s
the company introduced cost cutting
measures including a process to make its
milk last longer in production for this
they used a secret method called liosis
liosis
lipolysis the details of Hershey's
chocolate making process are a company
secret but part of the process involves
butc acid butc acid extends the shelf
life of milk but it does partially sour
it it's also found in Parmesan cheese
fermented foods like sauerkraut and of
course vomit Hershey's became a powerful
Chocolate Company in the US so much so
they successfully forced a ban on an
import of Cadbury's chocolate into the
US in 1988 Hershey's acquired the US
cadb license and has been producing it
in the US with their own Americanized
formula putting them in similar looking
cadb packages ever since remember the
price section from earlier well it turns
out that not only are Americans paying
basically double the price for chocolate
as we are but they're also getting a
worse quality product that's kind of
sad 100 G of dairy milk chocolate in the
UK contains the following 534 calories
30 G of fat of which 18 G are saturated
57 G of carbs of which 56 G of sugars
and 56 mg of sodium let's compare that
to a 99 G bar over here seeing as
there's only one G difference 500
calories 57.5 G of carbs 27.5 G of total
fat 17.5 G of saturated fat 55 G of
total sugars 7.5 g of protein and 100
Mig of sodium if we compare the 100 G
stats in the UK to the 99 G stats in the
US you'll find that the UK actually has
slightly more calories in fat although
it has less carbs and much less sodium
give me I was going to say a weekend but
I think realistically one hung over
Sunday